tá funcionando aqui tá me ouvindo
o evento é o evento mais incrível
principalmente os empreendedores sociais
não é mara primária porque eu acho que é
um espaço onde a gente pode contar nossa
história dos poucos espaços que existem
nesse mundo né
eu vou contar um pouco dessa história
pra você começou em 2002 eu tinha 22
anos de idade era uma menina estava indo
bem
estava me formando em duas faculdades
como manda o figurino e estava
trabalhando em uma multinacional
até que uma amiga minha volta de uma
viagem que ela fez na nova zelândia
completamente encantada pelo mundo fala
assim vamos sair daqui vamos sair desse
status covão viajavam conhecer o mundo
vamos fazer alguma coisa diferente está
todo mundo fazendo igual eu sou uma
pessoa inquieta levando a gente começou
e renata em 2002
a gente tinha reuniões assim a gente se
encontrava na casa dela abriu um mapa
mundi na nossa frente e começar a
escolher os países que a gente queria
passar a gente terminou com uma lista de
79 países ea gente decidiu que a gente
ia ficar dois anos viajando foi renata
dois anos viajando vagando pelo mundo
vão fazer alguma coisa vamos fazer um
projeto vão criar alguma coisa
bom não criar alguma coisa mas um time
não libero criar a gente resolveu ligar
o amyr klink pegou o telefone e ligou
para o escritório amyr klink e falamos
com as pessoas de comunicação dele ele
foi super querido recebeu a gente falou
assim olha pra criar um projeto vocês
começam por aqui e vão por ali mas uma
coisa muito importante tem que saber o
que vocês querem é que o objetivo não é
objetivo não pode ser só vi a janela
então vamos ter que buscar o objetivo
começamos a estudar essa coisa social
era muito nova não tinha muita noção do
que estava acontecendo e aí descobrimos
que a gente queria visitar pequenas
iniciativas sociais que deram certo lá
fora
montar um portal na internet e tentar
trazer essas idéias do brasil para
terceiro setor e os jovens pensarem
entender como é que a gente podia se
envolver com ações mais sociais
montamos um projeto realista e 2003
o projeto era pequenininho renata mudou
pra minha casa a primeira coisa que a
gente fez foi vender foi vender todas as
nossas roupas executiva no bazar na casa
dela sapato alto terninho essas coisas
que não nos pertence ao mais vendeu
essas roupas conseguimos seis mil reais
esse bazar e aí a nossa vida começou o
projeto realiza começou a nascer
a gente era metida então a gente pegar o
telefone e começaram a tentar captar
recurso a gente fez um site virou um
portal tem diário todas as histórias da
viagem foram para lá a gente foi parar
no ministério das relações exteriores
conseguimos o apoio do mr é o ministro
celso lata e recebeu nós duas na no
gabinete dele em brasília ea gente assim
uniformizadas terninho achando que nós
eram as pessoas super importante ea
gente conseguiu fechar várias parcerias
foram mais de 15
assim ligando para a sadia e falando que
ia falar presidente por sua secretária
que gostaria de falar
alice freitas do projeto e alicia
a gente marcou reunião do banco real a
gente conseguiu entrar empresa que nunca
imaginava que a gente possa conseguir na
cara de pau uma ignorância convicta
a gente sabia que a gente tava certo é
que a gente queria fazer aquilo e aquilo
ia dar certa bem saímos de um jornal
onde conseguiu tudo como parceria
assessoria de imprensa é coisa foi foi
acontecendo e resolvemos viajar
a gente fez índia bangladesh tailândia e
vietnã
foi uma viagem muito intenso a gente
vivia como eles viviam a gente pegava os
meios de transporte que eles usavam e só
ficávamos em casa de família das
famílias dos projetos sociais que a
gente ia visitar
foram quatro meses visitando projetos
a gente encontrou mais de vinte e cinco
iniciativas incríveis e colocamos todas
as iniciativas no site
voltamos quatro quilos mais magra eu já
não aguento mais olhar para a cara da
outra porque depois de um ano e meio
juntos regional vão divorciar um
pouquinho a gente entender como é que
vai funcionar a gente não conseguiria
mais viajar a gente já tinha feito
precisava fazer não vão voltar ao
mercado de trabalho e um dos pesados que
a gente visitou é a geração de renda que
a gente tinha na lista para pesquisar eu
fiquei absolutamente encantada por
geração de renda
as pessoas estavam fazendo isso muito
devagar ninguém sabia bem como ne
segundo e terceiro setor com o terceiro
setor
eu falei isso quero fazer da minha vida
passei dois anos trabalhando na rega eis
que eu reencontra uma amiga minha nova
friburgo aquelas que tinham tá
sentadinho ali e raquel estava voltando
a suíça largou o emprego milionário e
estava super feliz naquela terra gelada
voltou pra cá e ficou desempregado foi
raquel desempregada ela era a parte
comercial eu falei é perfeita pra montar
uma história comigo e comecei a
convencer a gente começou a conversar
vamos montar um negócio geração de renda
disse que que é isso de renda disse
vamos entender então a gente começou a
capacitando um grupo quando falou
capacitando gente naquela época vocês
perguntando em qual é a metodologia que
usava eu vou falar assim a metodologia e
nem sabia o que era metodologia direito
mas resolveu que a gente queria apoiar
um grupo de mulheres de 30 mulheres que
ficavam em campo grande
dentro de uma cooperativa de catadores a
quem vendeu o carro dela eu saí do
afroreggae e fiquei fazendo bico pra
gente conseguir bancar enquanto agente
bancava a capacitação eu achei bandeira
do pt
fiz depilação a laser nas amigas enfim
todos os bicos possíveis a gente fez
nesse período em que a gente estava é
tentando construir essa história
treinamos essas mulheres e na que em
2005 nós éramos 33 pessoas
essa foi nossa primeira marca nos brasil
ea gente começou a vender os produtos e
percebemos que essa é a maior
dificuldade delas vender ninguém
conseguia produzir e levar o produto no
mercado
e a gente foi descobrir que de fato a
gente teve loja shopping
a gente começou a exportar a gente
começou a entender esse mercado aqui ao
centro na parte comercial tocando essa
história eu mais junto com as meninas
organizando o que eu acho que a gente
conseguiu impactar mais pessoas vendendo
o produto delas
e aí teve um momento é da conta de luz
que o chamamento continua estava bem daí
dá nada não tinha dinheiro para pagar a
conta de luz do escritório que já estava
ficando e de repente a mônica que essa
pessoa que está com uma auréola asinhas
de anjo ela entrou fazendo a unha mônica
nossa manicura lá de vez em quando e
sempre levava natura avon essas
coisinhas que vender quando a mônica
chega esse dia a gente não tinha
dinheiro para a conta de luz
mas a gente comprou olhos deve alguma
coisa tá batendo e quando a gente
percebeu essa grandeza da venda direta
na mesma hora a gente olhou década outra
falou assim ah isso vão montar a
primeira rede venda direta de produtos
inclusive país
inscrevemos a história a idéia era muito
boa a gente pegou uma bolsa chama de
produto fala mônica vai vender e ver o
que você acha a música foi uma bolsa
cheia de artesanato e voltou uma semana
depois que a bolsa vazia
isso é maravilhoso descrevemos o projeto
e aí fomos sim que acatar recurso porque
a gente não aguentava mais depois de
dois anos ficar bancando o nosso próprio
bolso a coisa já não tava indo tão bem
na fundação avina foi a primeira
organização que apoiou nossa história é
a gente foi descobrir nasceu asta que é
a primeira rede de venda direta de
produtos sustentáveis nesse país quiçá
do mundo que a gente nunca encontrou
nada parecido é um catálogo como
qualquer outro de venda direta natura
avon e as pessoas podem vender leva na
sua bolsa e começa a mostrar para as
amigas e redes de relacionamento
só fui entender esse universo existem no
brasil uma piada de 25 mil grupos
produtivos se ações cooperativas de
mulheres que fazem alguma coisa com as
mãos
são mais de duas milhões de pessoas que
sobrevivem disso unicamente disso a
grande maioria tem dificuldade de vender
então elas não conseguem votar os seus
produtos no mercado ea gente resolveu
que a gente ia fazer isso
o primeiro catálogo foi um fiasco vocês
conseguem enxergar o preço
cento e oitenta e um reais e trinta e
quatro centavos a gente na hora idéia de
como fazer um cavalo foi uma zona
exportava os modelos
fotografava e achava que estava bonito
os preços eram completamente desconexos
a coisa não funcionou ea gente falou
agora as conselheiras que são as
consultoras que a gente começou a trazer
para a rede não fazem parte do perfil de
pessoas que não conseguirem desse tipo
de produto né
é nós reunimos 24 grupos produtivos
nessa época eram mais ou menos 290
pessoas artesãs
eis que chega à nossa vida uma mulher
chamada rosane rosa que também está
sentadinho ali ea rosane de varejo era
do time é do ponto frio e ela fala o
seguinte são muito corajosos eu vou
tentar ver se eu consigo fazer alguma
coisa por vocês e ela ajuda a gente a
organizar essa visão varejista que a
gente não tinha
montamos o primeiro catálogo e ela falou
uma coisa muito sábia
essa rede não vai vir de fora para
dentro
ela vem de dentro pra fora então ele vai
pra sua casa em chamas cinco amigas
essas cinco amigas vão ver as primeiras
conselheiros da asta revendedoras eu
faço mesmo raquel faz o mesmo e assim
foi no início de 2008 a rede asta em
2008 tinha sete conselheiros
eu minha mãe em a dinda raquel rosane e
nós chegamos em 2012 e 800 conselheiros
são 50 grupos produtivos hoje apoiados
pela rede são mais ou menos 800 artesã
antes impactadas
fechamos em quatro canais de venda em
2008 a gente vendeu 7 mil reais o ano
inteiro e ano passado a gente fechou o
faturamento 625 mil reais por catálogo
vendendo os produtos
nós hoje somos uma rede mais ou menos
duas mil pessoas impactadas direta e
indiretamente a gente assiste todos os
dias essas transformações
alguns casos de sucesso são muito
bacanas é eu vou mostrar as fotos de
antes e depois que vocês vêem essas
mulheres foi assim que eu encontrei numa
associação em sergipe perde aracaju
ela estava assim e hoje elas são assim o
lugar que elas trabalhavam era assim e
hoje é assim
tudo porque elas receberam investimento
começaram a focar o seu trabalho e
conseguiram mudar a vida das pessoas que
estavam em volta delas através do
trabalho e tem essa pessoa que chama
lúcia é um dos maiores casos de sucesso
da artista
há um tempo atrás ela chegou pra mim
chorando chegou pra gente chorando muito
desesperada que ela não conseguia fazer
um bom produto ela não conseguia vender
e ela não aguentava mais investindo uma
coisa que não dava certo
a gente falou não vamos criar uma
coleção com você e você vai dar ser
assim porque o fuxico nós que vai estar
na moda e está sempre na moda ea gente
vai conseguir fazer você vender ela hoje
eu acho que ela veio aqui contar um
pouco da história delas pra vocês
lúcia é pra quê
boa tarde muzzi filho me desculpe mas
dizer hoje da asta tem que contar um
pouco da infância que eu te porque minha
mãe
nós éramos são fidélis e minha e todos
os meus irmãos que mais ela nos 8 fomos
criado na roça e minha irmã mais velha
veio por rio de janeiro veio tentar a
sorte e minha mãe ficou em são fidélis
desesperada porque no rio de janeiro ea
irmã ficou grávida ainda época isso era
um absurdo e vi ela juntou todos os
filhos e viemos para o rio de janeiro e
eu como caçula a minha mãe foi que mais
me prendeu nunca me deixando trabalhar
fora ela falou você vai ser criada para
poder estudar
estudei até o primeiro ano do segundo
grau e você vai casar você vai ser
dependente do teu esposo e nada mais do
que isso e isso me incomodava porque eu
via um rio de janeiro e mês e eu queria
alcançar muito mais do que ela estava
propondo pra mim e apareceu um curso no
sied do qual eu fiz eram 38 trinta e
oito jovens de várias comunidades e ali
obtive o meu sonho realizado
posso falar pra vocês o valor do meu
sonho
na época foi 50 reais aquele 50 reais
pra mim nossa parecia um milhão e eu
fiquei muito feliz da vida porque foi o
meu primeiro dinheiro que eu coloquei na
minha mão e eu tomei gosto e dizer quero
o meu dinheiro e não sabia o que ia
fazer com ele e aí comecei a tomar gosto
do meu dinheiro da minha renda comecei a
trabalhar fazendo curso
montamos mopeia flash card que nós
tínhamos que escolher o que quisesse
o que nós iríamos fazer um biscoito da
vovó trabalhar com o jornal foi pintado
fuxico desses 38 jovens só ficou eu
porque eu queria dar conta
unidade é o meu sonho que era ter o meu
dinheiro
casei tive três filhos wesley fabiano e
caroline carol 19 anos hoje o ex militar
fabiano são genish ua dos sonhos e eu
não podia trabalhar fora
tive que parar aí eu falei vou esperar e
esquecer um pouquinho continuei e aí
nesse sonho apareceu eu desesperada
porque minha mãe ficou doente um sonho
se realizando ao mesmo tempo tive que
escolher entre realizar o meu sonho que
era participar do fashion business
diferente negócio ou ficar com a minha
mãe que estava com câncer
optei ao nosso ver que deixaram sonha em
ficar com a minha mãe porque ela tem
três meses de vida optei fiquei com ela
mas quando eu falei acabou tudo pra mim
aparece ali se raquel em campo grande
eu falando com a minha amiga acabou
porque eu tenho que ficar com a minha
mãe e meu sonho vai ser realizado vai
fechar a porta porque é uma feira de
negócios
eu falei vai ser fechado e apareceu ali
se raquel para poder mudar a minha vida
porque aonde que eu pensei que eu não
iria conseguir conseguir porque essas
mulheres meio porque aonde que é tudo
difícil pra mim se tornou fácil através
dessas mulheres porque havia um produto
mas não tinha qualidade para poder
entrar no negócio foi todo modificado
a artesã há a estilista chegou já vamos
montar um produto pra você bacana que tu
vai vender que foi a almofada fugir cão
tiramos o primeiro lugar de vendas em
viajei para florianópolis eram de sexo
ó máximo a minha renda de 50 reais
quando nós temos encomendas um favor
vocês cobram uns acham por favor você
está ajudando uma família
cheguei a tirar dois mil reais de r$50 a
hoje meu esposo que eu tinha que
perguntar me dão é a vida dez reais pra
que ele me pede emprestado eu falo com
juros e correção monetária
eu agradeço muito por todos vocês e eu
falar dia do impossível aconteceu na
minha vida e fala de transformação
também aconteceu na minha vida porque
meus filhos ver uma nova mulher e eu
mesmo me vejo uma lúcia criada pela mãe
de um jeito e hoje nós lelis
eu agradeço a todos
lua e se a gente conseguiu
você pega você também pode você tem
realize o seu sonho porque nada é
impossível
ali obrigado por